I thought we could start with the
English because it's one of the more
common openings I was thinking there's
two opening that you could try to
achieve because you're a Benoni player
but you're also a Grand Prix player I
was thinking like rivers from pre is
probably the pick that would be most up
your alley
mmm the problem with with being a benoni
player you can see before you can't
always get up into any structure because
usually a white keeps the decline back
like I know this is one of your recent
games you play tonight at 3 your
opponent played d3 and you started
thinking forever yeah like you don't
want to take five minutes on the move -
you want to have some game plan in mind
I think the great thing about just 25
against e4 is that normally okay at
least my recommendation if you pursue it
there's a very simple setup to play
you're it's essentially just a reverse
grand prix you're down a tempo so
there's some some differences but in
many cases you'll still have these
attacking ideas on the Kings side
because most English players will
usually develop like Bishop g3 Bishop g2
and then you'll still get some attacking
potential okay yeah and I can actually
rename this chapter reverse and 3/4 this
English so I can show you just some like
introductory lines and this is I will
say this is one of the very first
openings I learned against English maybe
I should change around the move order
but usually things transpose y can start
with my c3 or g3 um usually combination
of these and I recommend at 5 early but
you might even risky but normally
against most English players you'll get
this setup
this is where things can start deviating
but those players will play III in this
position which is actually a move you
would usually like to see because
there's a very cool response which maybe
you you already saw what I had input but
the response here is pawn to d5 which
can catch a lot of players off-guard
because White has three attackers on e5
and you only have two defenders the nice
thing about d5 is completely sound move
because there are many cases like if
white tries to win the pawn you'll have
this resource night before and d3 is
actually quite weak so just to
illustrate let's say a cat5 right before
you have an immediate threat of 93 and
there's a really only one good move in
this position of her whites which is not
everyone plays well I'll pose the
question to you what's what's really the
only reasonable move for whites deep g3
is is really only move for whites I
could just show some other options a lot
of players will go wrong by playing d4
just trying to open the center but this
is really bad after you for and then the
knight is coming to d3 and iPad games
which very quickly golden box favor like
white plays 92 and 193 check and the
King F 1 and then 94 and i2 is falling
so white has to be a bit more cautious
from earlier I've also had games where
players will play Queen 84 and forget
that the knight is defended by the
bishop so then after Bishop d7 93 will
come
followed by e4 and also a great position
for for black so d3 only move you can
win the back upon the sneakiest move to
play might feel more natural so playing
Nightbeat 85 but the seer and in my
opinion the better move is they take
night I take D 5
and the reasoning is now you have a
threat in this position and actually
again white only has one good move in
this position everything else for whites
would be a blunder so what's really the
only move for a white here
I'm trying to see that when is the
winner de bomb exactly got it so to
defend it you don't like cash unite
yourself
yeah White House to capture and this
this can be very effective in list
because a lot of players will just
assume there's no threat play ninety two
and then your you take on c3 take on d3
and you're happy okay if light realizes
has to take then you take back it's a
very playable position I mean you have
more space you provoked white to play d3
so sometimes the structure is a little
bit weak especially the d3 pawn whatever
III energy three-hour play there's some
additional weaknesses and you have a
very simple simple completion of
development like c6 is a very useful
move to support the night and try and
undermine the white bishop and your
bishops come in the center you castle
that's a very reasonable middle game
yeah black score is also like the scores
are I think quite well here for black in
the database at least based on based on
approximately not hundred games that
have reached this position okay
sometimes again you can't always trust
like the highest level games but
certainly very playable for black and
you play this into enemies as well like
you learn this when I first learned this
yes I I had reasonable success with a
very good success online in the the
quicker time controls because a lot of
players would just start thinking after
d5 I can show also like there I would
run into many cases where white would
take on d5 not with a pawn but like with
the Knights and you can see this is this
is quite high scoring for black because
box essentially going to use the same
idea if you take again and whenever
white takes back with you're gonna play
94 next yeah so yeah if like if see take
d5 Knight before
and again the whole point is accessing
the d3 slur I have to find the game
there is a game I played like three or
four years ago I want to play Queen to
b3 attempting to keep everything under
control and then hold on to the pod but
then of course again
efore very common theme and okay black
is having all the fun
and also like either what getting 93 or
waiting the pawn back it's a nice
position I wonder is that an e3 wouldn't
they play like night after we or so but
other common things here yeah Knight f3
is certainly a move that will sometimes
be played early I'm thinking about like
this specific position it could just run
into e4
oh poor is overextending but II for
looks attractive maybe need to be
Thursday so yeah this is another main
line like most often you'll run into d3
or III because it's actually online yeah
yeah when you played teeth Rios is it's
very early like usually white will play
g3 first but the whole idea is to get
like a reverse Sicilian where white has
extra tempo and I would bet a lot of
money that your opponent was either like
a knight or for a dragon player as black
if he's playing c4 d3 he's hoping to
transpose into maybe his favorite black
opening with an extra tempo with this
line you don't play like the open
Sicilian you keep it more of a closed
Sicilian and nice thing about that is
the extra tempo isn't always that
important because it's more focused on
what setup you're employing and it
doesn't get tactical right away at least
in this line the move I recommend here
is Bishop to b4 where usually if you're
provoked you'll take on c3 and then I'll
be the same Senate but like and then
you'll be familiar with the structure
and all the attacking ideas like Queenie
a queen h5 so I I included a game here a
really nice scheme by a really strong
Grandmaster who is actually one of my
favorite players to observe his openings
because he plays really offbeat stuff
for a very high level player was a game
of rigged rapport and okay you played
this with very good success as black and
this game like i play naturally like a
three Bishop takes c3 and then black
essentially employed all of like the
thematic kind of attacking maneuvers in
the early middle game like okay III so
starting with Queen eight shades or
queenie eight and eventually queen h5
also King h8 very useful move to to keep
the King out of danger
especially like sometimes this diagonal
can be weak when you play out five so
early and okay the sound up was nice it
still took work to win the game
like played b5 that's very common like
when white expands on the queenside you
just maneuver your knight towards the
Kings side my play Queen to d2 here now
there is an interesting moment here
where black is leaving the be silent
pawn undefended and I didn't have a
chance to analyze this too extensively
but it might take some b7 maybe we can
we can try and identify what black would
do in this position that there are a few
few interesting attacking ideas sure da
is the most attractive
you said Pawnee 400 G 4 oh yeah nighty
Knight to g4 it's fighting mated one and
probably forcing h4 yeah that can be met
me with GTI or g5 yeah that's probably
the most aggressive approach yeah I'm
I'm looking around not seeing anything
so clear I was thinking and another
approach is to play off for you get the
ship into play like that's the Bishop t4
unlock would be sacking the exchange
maybe it would be worth it we can check
the engine here because like engines can
be very strong in this position and see
what it recommends well white is better
okay brother from a human standpoint
Mike is still gonna be having some fun
I'm wondering if if we just like start
taking deep if that didn't will change
his mind
Rick eight actually seems reasonable
yeah the engine is just counting the
pawns it sees White's up upon doesn't
see any immediate mates
so it's selecting white 0.8 now it's
limping like my student that's actually
a really good sign when you like
continue to leave the engine running it
will like keep dropping and evaluation
in your favor let's yeah let's see my
fee for each four
and sometimes you got to play out the
line for it to fully understand Knight
g6 is really interesting because it
allows Bishop take h8 now it's getting
insane
like oh well if you take on each four
then white and blacks 20 so Anthony
asleep lay so it's important
understanding these lines like black is
winning because there's no good way to
stop Queen each to check in that
relation what does it sing Oh f3 Wow
f3 is such a weird move allowing night -
III dive into this a little Queen and I
think after what is this line
ah f3 also looks really yeah 92 got
three because now the threat is Queen h2
so the bishop can't take on that fee the
rook has to take on sv and then still
probably queen h2 checking up on drip
take aids block is wait block is down a
rook
Black's Khalid rook in the computer is
only saying plus one which is usually a
good sign
maybe too risky but okay like in a
practical game if you're if you're going
into this knowing it's okay it's gonna
be a hard fight I would probably still
go into this realizing that white is
walking a very thin tightrope yeah
especially if I take some use out of it
very very risky when I'm actually
curious I'm gonna if you wanna go in
that line I wonder what happens in 1983
which is like whites temporarily up a
full rock yeah so some material back
yeah but white is still better
interesting okay yes you already this so
basically the feeder saying like you
you're a down material so even if you
take on III you're gonna witness your
back but still be down
well like concrete variation is after
night take III Queen d2
you win f1 and then you probably just
when eight the problem is like f 3 is
now defended so you're not getting as
much counter play like you could take on
each four and you have how many pawns
from piece to pawns for the piece it's
still playable like white still has to
defend accurately I think you got ideas
of lifting the rook over and there's no
immediate it's a counter play for whites
but yeah of course the computers gonna
perfer whites in this position of course
this isn't like ah probably isn't like a
realistic like specific variation to
study but over the overall ideas in this
variation are quite interesting where
there there might be many cases where
you allow the b7 plan to just be
undefended and you go for the kingside
play and the combination of 94 or 99 to
g6 and stacking on each four is quite
interesting we see in this game like did
not want to take the risk and okay why
tried to play a bit more in controlled
fashion with f4 stopping back from
playing a floor which is probably the
main idea and in many cases like what
black did like it's it was a kind of
positional buildup but there's always
there's always pressure on whites
he got she was kind of unusual I like
night I hate preparing g5 trying to open
up files and there's some one of our
grind because it was just God became a
closed position sometimes you have to
react to the structure
and there is a moment in this game
really unexpected move but it kind of
goes to show the creativity of a black
playing Knights d5 just asking a piece
we can just be taken by a pawn and wife
took the piece given that 93 is coming
and the amazing thing was that f4 is now
about to happen and Locke is just
crashing through it's just massive
compensation I'm not sure what the
computer would think about this but it's
just really interesting to see that my
black just keeps momentum even at the
cost of material and then the finish is
pretty devastating for whites so losing
losing any shelter the king had and the
pawns get rolling this is already just
over so anyway I mean the game itself
maybe will offer some interesting ideas
but hopefully this is a starting point
at least where I think if you were gonna
play this sign this black you would want
to know the sign with Bishop c5 in d5 or
sorry defy first if they play e3 if I
play d3 then you put the bishop on b4
and playing in Grand Prix style I think
it's a lot more about kind of
understanding that the middle game plans
and the knowing it specific lines sounds
good
I think one of the best approaches is to
just find find some high-level games
like um use the opening explorer
applying games where black wins play
through them and as you start playing
through more and more then hopefully
you'll start seeing like recurring ideas
especially in the middle game how strong
players will actually execute these
kingside attacks and that's one of the
quickest ways to build knowledge in a
specific opening structure so uh I don't
think I want to overwhelm you with like
too many other English variations I
think this is like as good starting
point especially because these lines are
probably most expected if you're playing
an English player and then over time
like if you run into something a bit
different and can of course add on to it
yeah I'm curious
before even d5 right here like what is
what is the objective of this English
opening what a nation accomplished like
if I dunno sure
yeah well whites so when players play
the English open because I used to play
in English for many years it's still in
my repertoire
it's a self-paced opening where white
usually goes for 92 in castling
if white accomplishes this set up then
it's harmonious like there would be
ideas further applying d4 for a white
expanding the center also playing 95
because there's so much control over the
d5 square and maybe even the eventual
night e to c3
there's also ideas of a a 3 B 4 that's a
very positional opening essentially
trying to go for a closed Sicilian where
like in these closed Sicilian positions
the main goal is so I control this key
center square in this case d5 in Black's
territory and then expand on the Queen
side so a lot of players will play this
because it's it's different and it's
still a reasonable approach the thing
the thing that white has to watch out
for though is when black challenge is to
set up immediately and that's why I like
to recommend this d5 line because then
white can't really achieve what they
usually would like to achieve they have
to basically start defending against the
oncoming threats which is always in my
situation to be in ok players I usually
have a positional so by just jumping
this set up immediately there may be a
more look or like a little bit less
comfortable with playing in my territory
basically exactly and this line I will
say is pretty offbeat's
mmm I like it most players will not like
this is not a main line by any means
like most English players will encounter
encounter openings intending to like
transpose into d4 lines like they'll
encounter 80-65 they'll encounter like
Kings Indian but this is kind of unique
to the English which is which is a nice
spot to be yeah I'm curious after a
fight I don't normally play d5 is there
any chance where this line can transpose
a different line where maybe I'm the one
that's left very like he checking the
seafloor and then I blink I don't
believe I they don't I see I will say if
you're in doubt just follow this setup
like it ok all the arrows drawn yeah at
least let me get rid of arrows just like
follow this setup worst-case scenario I
think white might play some move like an
early a3 like let's actually let me show
you another move like they could trick
you and play a 3 here and then let's say
this is a tournament and you're on your
own
and you can't go for d5 anymore because
8 3 is stopping any night before ideas
what would you do I remember in the book
the grant read when you recommended me
whenever they play a 6 really early you
being caribou bishop yes she said
yeah drawing from this little fight you
the same I think that's why it's good
for you to kind of have already have
this experience playing Grand Prix as
white because then you're already
familiar with maybe how to react to new
moves so g6 is uh is what I would go for
and then it's some more of a close
Sicilian setup there would still be
middle game plans of attacking on the
kingside very common after you castle
after you played e6
it's commented by h6 g5 and then
maneuver the Knight to g6 also to maybe
throw in c6 and then later play f4 so
that's another kind of like default
setup like if the the specific
preparation doesn't work out you can
kind of default to the setup and there's
not too many ways that light can throw
you off guard I mean you're you're
making me think now like how how I could
potentially deviate
maybe there's one line that comes to
mind which I played myself as my f3 in
this position which is a bit different
because most players will feed in keto
the LightSquared Bishop right away this
is a move to be prepared for
I wouldn't prioritize it when learning
English but it's good at least not to be
completely thrown off guard where let's
say you play at five now then I can play
d4 and then the center is challenged
immediately and now now the ball is kind
of in your court do you take on d4 do
you play E for to try and defend your
equal and somehow what would be your
first impression here I feel like I
would be better just Center control my F
pawn is out and my Denis be fair enough
yeah I will say that this is another
kind of opening line it's kind of
offbeat for both sides because white
usually doesn't doesn't play Knight f3
as a main move and black doesn't like a
5 Zameen move so we're entering kind of
a lesser-known variation like if you
pick a random chess player off the
street they probably won't know anything
about this variation
I will say it's very playable for a back
you kind of have to know what you're
doing the best move here is eb-5 or
exciting for to gain space cake the
nights it is may be somewhat
overextending now there's a couple lines
here for white usually light will either
play Knight g5 or a Bishop g5
oh I'll show you a fun variation let's
say this is g5 you develop play Knight
f6 now White's 9 is attacked and if they
play 92 which is what they would like to
play you can win d4 actually there's a
really fun line funny line that I'm just
realizing I don't know if I
I think I've seen this before actually
but it just came to mind that if you
take on d4 white could try and counter
with taking on e4
[Music]
and then attack the G fortnight I was
thinking because somehow sac the Queen
but now I'm realizing that doesn't make
any sense not sure you could take back
actually maybe you just shouldn't take
on d4
you should play something perhaps a bit
more sound like Bishop to b4 this would
be a reasonable approach and then just
get ready to castle play this and it's
still somewhat in the style of Grand
Prix right later you want to maneuver
your Queen to the Kings side I wanted to
show a specific line which it features
like a really cool trap really bizarre
trap to wear sometimes players will play
d5 to counter attack the knight on c6
and
this this position has actually never
occurred in me chest or the Masters
database but I know it's occurred I have
like a chest based out of this with like
seven million games or something I know
it's occurred in that database
but I guess there's no games in either
of the chest databases
anyway I wanted to show a line where you
take the Knights today take your knight
then you take on g2
as it's a messy situation there's like
lights taking your son you're taking my
stuff and then what move seems most
logical for white here like if you were
white what would be your first
impression
yeah they take on d7 with Chuck and then
recapture on g2 taking on g7 with chalk
is actually a losing move
now I want you to think blacks and move
and play the winning move
um I bet you something crazy like 98
CSUN yeah cuz your paws on g2 your paw
is one square away from queening so
you're happy to sacrifice your Creek on
d8 to then take the rook on each one and
meanwhile you're attacking the bishop
which is undefended so you're guaranteed
to add material here when I'm going to
beat England edition well we should say
C sin instead of night then you don't
want anything cuz it takes you to Oh
Internet I'll take you on g5 exactly
it's really funny tactic like to get out
of check and leave your queen hanging
that goes to show and you have a pawn so
close to promoting you can do weird
stuff yeah exactly yeah I like a lot of
players will be inclined to just take
with check now okay if I take Sanji to
immediately probably the best move and
then you just take back and it's a
playable position it's it's dynamic like
you could probably off a weaker players
and if you prepare it well enough you
can be okay against stronger players as
well but again it's a very rare line so
I don't think you would have to it's too
often yeah I will say much more common
is Knight g5 with the idea to eventually
reposition the knight on f4 and get some
kind of bind where white would
eventually like to play h4 to reinforce
an item prevent you from playing g5 and
I've studied this opening before and
there's a move that is really
interesting here to play h6
usually white will play Knight to h3 and
then you can play g5 uh which looks way
overextending like you've used Spence
almost a full opening just pushing King
side pawns but that you're really
putting the questions in the night like
what is it doing on each three and
surprisingly one of the most common
moves here for white is to play Knight
to g1 and this this is a line which
again it's pretty less common in the
database like for the box side
but black scores quite quite reasonably
like its if we look at this position
after each six it's about even like 30
34 34 32 so I've got about 50 games and
I think it leads to reasonable play like
your next several moves are going to be
quite naturally I have six Bishop g7
currently throw in d6 maybe later
maneuver your Knight to d6 you just want
to make sure your your pawns are
reinforced and not becoming becoming
targets
Wow yeah I remember looking at the Yasir
game
yeah I'm very clear memories because I
used to play this from the white side
I think the Oscars opponents play
tonight she won if I'm not mistaken
yeah Wow with idea to play h4 next and
then after Bishop g7 wasn't h4 or Nasser
probably played some different moves
maybe not at six yeah right and then I
have some big memory of the King walking
to g6 I'll just go ahead and insert this
game he inspired by ah sir oh he played
g4 which looks really anti positional
because it gives us F for square but it
keeps the King side closed so the black
king will actually be safe and 9 h5 is
crazy like Bach his pistol bangs from
the opening principles I like putting
the knight on the edge moving the same
piece twice but the idea is to fight for
control maybe even not having ideas of
g3 moving the same 80 oh he wants to he
wants to maybe do this he might also
want to like do this in this like c65
get some French structure you side is
under control yeah very strange game
yeah
you look at Yasir games and sometimes
are there like just really weird and
crazy to understand but sometimes he'll
have like really interesting ideas in
the opening if you enjoy the style
recommend looking at Gosford games crazy
and while well he's he likes to be he
likes to be a genius we're a little come
up with kind of really crazy ideas and
then just make them work somehow one
game that really comes to mind is if you
type in do a Google search yasser King
d7 there's some game where like randomly
in the opening he just plays King g7
instead of developing anything and like
it was a brilliant move
and it led to just incredible play it
was like somebody Nonie
I was a it was like up here it's opening
and like he's really underdeveloped but
he plays King g7 and then if you're
interested I can I'll just bring in the
game is a new chapter it's it's the type
of thing like you probably don't want to
consume too much of especially like
before going into a tournament because
then you'll be like overly inspired to
do crazy suck and then it won't work
outs that happened to me once like I've
I went to a test camp and the lecturer
was like all about sacrifice
positional sacrifices and then I play
that tournament and then every game I
wanted to play a positional sacrifice
but nothing worked
and but like some sometimes like very
specific scenarios it will be playable
who's the guy you said the bottle to
feet openings Eagle Oh Igor black yeah
Igor I think there's an opening named
after him too but you can just make
I mean he's an older player
but sometimes you can like this go to
his chess games calm like profile and
just like start going through games or
even go to chess game calm and type in
the eco code of a student opening like
if you wanted do you know are you
familiar with eco codes I'm not that I
can okay this is actually a useful tip
if you want to look for games in a
certain opening by a certain player I'll
just give you one example that like
let's say you want to look at four
nights with a three sure we can see in
the chests this says C 46 on the top
where it identifies the opening when I
yield on the white opens 10 women
looking it turnoff stalkerish
okay go scroll up
two white with a wide openings yes yes
nature and then scroll up into the
notation
other notation
do you see my screen
yeah I see your screen so turn off
opening book and then go all the way
back to move one yeah so you see c-46
like we'll say the name of the opening
oh dear
yeah as soon as it will change depending
what happens see Pony safe I see so I'm
gonna just do a quick Google search of
Igor black c-46 and it should come up in
chest Gamescom
yeah so I'll send a link in this chat
here
of what you would search in tests games
and then you can find all the games by
black where that matches opening code no
that's pretty badass
he's played this so many times okay now
actually he I think he plays g3 more
than a three and unfortunately they
share the same opening code costs you
might have to do some further digging
all I see is it an 8-3 g3 but there are
games I know with with a three played
but yeah he probably plays g3 more often
well yeah and this is a feature that I
was going to say if you if you had test
base it's either it's a kind of filter
through players but come combining
likely chest and chest Gamescom can
usually be good enough and maybe this
wasn't the best example because it shows
this g3 comes up more often but for all
the other openings that can like it can
work quite well yeah okay cool I'm
looking at the ICD by the way I moved
foreign seen Indies in it
yeah it's that's pretty this is how it
comes out of nowhere but the king is
completely safe on the queenside and the
whole idea was to connect the the rook
in the Queen's so work h8 can be played
and then eventually later on the Queen
comes to eight sheets and everything
came into place because amazing
coordination of black pieces and they're
looking you know that's not like like
yeah like I like to show this position
to people because it's just so out of
the ordinary if you like this there's
another I think there's Karpov king e7
again scoffs key will be play in the
middle game just it's just yeah it's
just so random yeah it's a beautiful car
ball game actually
at some point if you want to stay
organized I recommend maybe moving these
games to a different study maybe have a
study just devoted for like classic
games but feel free to take a look at
these in your own time we can still
focus on openings if you like what yeah
but the idea is he wants to play g5 and
that he can't play g5 right away because
Bishop to g5 Hawaii astir rook and
amazingly it's so hard to stop g v g5
shafts oh my queen
the in state unit yeah house q was
provoked basically to give away a pawn
that the name line was 95 and then
blacks just 1 upon like when a fire
shack in black is up upon her so issues
with the king but there's enough to
eventually win the game
nice I really like this is opening
theory right now like kini savin's the
most-played move in this position okay
yeah um I think we were just finishing
off the green curry only like three oh
yeah with this light a three line and
then a 5e for ya but I think I think the
most important thing is that now you
have a starting point
mm-hmm so with all of these lines like
at least you you kind of have a starting
point where you you know the first few
moves and then ultimately you'll
probably get a position where it won't
be the terminal you'll be determined
later on in the game but hopefully it
will give you some momentum like you'll
you'll kind of know the the early ideas
and that's that will hopefully be a
better place than where you were maybe a
week ago where you were thinking for
five minutes to move to